كان الأحد أمس أكثر الأيام دموية
حتى الآن منذ
بدء هذا الصراع قبل أسبوع وبالطبع رغم
استمرار تلك الضربات
بين عشية وضحاها أه إسرائيل تقول إنها
تستهدف
أنفاق حماص في غزة
نعم تسمي تلك الأنفاق أه ليندا
ما يسمى بالمترو نظام أنفاق واسع النطاق
الادعاءات
التي تسمح لمقاتلي حماس ومسؤوليها
بالابتعاد عن أنظار الطائرات الإسرائيلية بدون طيار
وغيرها
من وسائل المراقبة أه يقولون
إنهم دمروا حتى الآن ما
يقرب من مائة كيلومتر من تلك
الأنفاق وطبعا تلك الأنفاق ستكون هي
حماس تلك  وغيرها من المنظمات في
غزة ستستخدم في حالة حدوث
توغل بري إسرائيلي توغل بري
لا يبدو أنه وشيك في هذه المرحلة على الرغم من
التغريدات الأخيرة
للجيش الإسرائيلي الآن في هذه الأثناء
أصبح الوضع في
غزة أكثر صعوبة
نتيجة لذلك.  من الغارات الجوية
نتيجة قطع الوقود من إسرائيل إلى
قطاع غزة ،
أصبح وضع الطاقة
أكثر صعوبة من أي وقت مضى  بالإضافة إلى تضرر نظام المياه بشدة ، ولجأ ما يصل إلى أربعين ألف شخص إلى مدارس الأونرا وهذه هي وكالة اللاجئين الفلسطينية لأنهم يأملون أن هذه المواقع لن أه تتضرر من الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية وهكذا. هذا الوضع الإنساني مستمر في التدهور بشكل كبير ووسط كل هذا ننسى أحيانًا أن هناك جائحة كوفيد مستمر تحدثنا إلى ممثل الأونرا اليوم الذي قال إن ما يصل إلى 30 في المائة من السكان في غزة أصيبوا أو أصيبوا بأه. من قبل الطمع ومن الواضح أن أي محاولة لتطعيم السكان أو اختبار السكان قد أعاقتها الأعمال العدائية المستمرة في مكان قال قبل بضع سنوات مسؤول كبير في الأمم المتحدة إن غزة حي فقير سامة